bonjour à tous le ch est idiote et je
suis lycéen
je voudrais vous parler aujourd'hui de
ma vision de la robotique domestique et
comment elles nous simplifiera la vie
dans un futur proche ce qui m'amène à ce
propos est une aventure qui m'est arrivé
l'année dernière c'était en février 2015
et j'aime été décidé de participer au
concours google s'agace faire avec un
projet de robot jardinier connectés
plein a pris trois mois pour réaliser ce
projet avec le profit de l'atelier
familial et de la bienveillance de mon
entourage
la tâche était énorme et c'était pour
moi et pour mes proches un vrai
tourbillon était parti sur l'idée de
remplacer toutes les tâches répétitives
du jardinage par un jeu sur smartphone
en vrai c'est pas gagné il me fallait
remplacer le binage l'arrosage le
repiquage que faisait quotidiennement
mon voisin retraité georges pour avoir
de si beaux légumes
ensuite on a fallu démontrer que c'était
faisable puisque l'idée c'était quand
même d'aller faire un petit tour en
californie chez google à mountain view
j'ai vraiment pu compter sur mon
entourage je vous allez voir d ingénieur
en robotique un centre de recherche m'a
aidé à réaliser certaines pièces
l'université voisine m'a ouvert ses
portes et mon père m'a aidé à réaliser
et concevoir le robot ainsi que son
habitat là j'ai été touché par l'accueil
de tous envers moi et mon projet tous
ont été très enthousiastes
ma mère est ma soeur on se met des
dizaines de petits pots de graines de
salades tomates de 40 pour les essais ma
grand-mère à chronométrer le temps
qu'elles passent et quotidiennement dans
son jardin pour enrichir mon étude mon
papy m'a expliqué comment fonctionner
les jardins lasagnes et même la couleur
de la serre a été choisi avec mon oncle
c'était très enrichissant et intéressant
au passage ce projet s'appelle botte de
carottes
c'est un jeu de mots la botte de
carottes françaises et cerise sur le
gâteau ça marche aussi en anglais avec
bottes pour vos potes
il m'a fallu expliquer tout ça dans un
dossier en ligne là je suis vraiment
éclaté
google demander des informations
précise et complète un vrai dossier de
recherche j'ai fait des vidéos des
diaporamas et des rapports d'expérience
et puis ce fut le grand soir à soir de
juin j'étais devant un pc avec ma
famille et google diffusé la liste des
quatre-vingt dix finalistes
quand j'ai vu mon nom à côté du drapeau
français j'ai été hyper content et ému
j'étais qualifié a été pour moi le début
d'une grande aventure qui me mena
jusqu'à un jury de scientifiques en
californie à montaigne but est d'abord
j'ai été contacté par le concours lépine
européen
j'ai présenté botte de carottes c'était
une sorte de baptême du feu il ne
marchait pas trop bien mais l'accueil
des gens fut très chouette et moraux
beau plaisait et puis je suis parti pour
la californie pour cinq jours avec mon
père tout fut pris en charge par google
et finalistes internationaux furent
accueillis dans un bel hôtel où les
organisateurs avaient installé un crash
pad a lieu où on pouvait discuter manger
se détendre échanger
j'ai rencontré des gens très
sympathiques même si on devait discuter
via l'intermédiaire des interprètes que
google avait engagé pondre les deux
jours suivants ont été studieux dans une
sorte de grand hall 20 stands présenter
les innovations des 20 finalistes
je vais présenter botte de carottes vont
un jury composé de googler de
scientifiques de chez national
geographic le journaliste de
scientifique american l'ingénieur de
chez virgin galactic ou encore de
créateurs de chez lego éducation sonia
l'interprète française m'a beaucoup aidé
contrairement à mon père qui était en
visite avec les autres parents à santa
cruz
google s'était en effet éloigné les
potentiels coach ce fut la soirée de la
remise des prix en transmises en direct
sur internet supérieures et puis très
simple à la fois
sergei bring le cofondateur de google
était présent avec ses enfants et il
était en bermuda et en europe
et puis je suis revenu des etats-unis
avec une belle coupe celle du prix
incubateur frais qui récompense les
travaux scientifiques prometteurs et la
ferme intention de ne pas m'arrêter là
google a également offert le mentorat de
steven à robotiser intra costaud il
enseigne la robotique à l'université
d'oslo et travaille pour google sur le
projet tango chaque mois on s'appelle
sur un gars ou pour échanger sur mes
projets de robots c'est une vraie chance
de connaître steven il est très fort et
toujours de bon conseil
il a également travaillé sur le robot
curiosity vous côté je continuer à
développer mon beau mais j'ai également
plein d'autres idées pour robotisée
notre quotidien je pense que l'époque
dans laquelle nous vivons est propice et
la robotique domestique
la technologie est descendu dans les
maisons je suis lycéen depuis peu et
j'ai à ma disposition des moyens de
création inimaginable il ya encore
trente ans le peuple prendra mémé dégoût
la brique mais storm permet de piloter
des moteurs détecter des couleurs ou
encore des obstacles de mesurer des
distances avec ce jouet on peut
facilement prototypes et des mécanismes
des comportements même complexe le mi6
distribue également aux enseignants et
aux élèves
le logiciel scratch cette application
permet d'aborder dès le plus jeune âge
la programmation graphique le tout 20 la
programmation objet le tout entièrement
graphiquement et sans écrire la moindre
ligne de code
je peux également usiner des pièces des
logiciels de création 3d gratuits
permettent de
faire de la ceao et j'ai la chance
d'avoir à la maison la fraiseuse
numérique de mon père je peux également
utiliser cette du lycée avec de simples
chute même de bois on peut facilement
réaliser des mécanismes fonctionnels
très rapidement et à faible coût
le design du wiltshire self est
également très à la mode
imaginez que vous vouliez réaliser un
robot qui arrive dans le linge au fond
du jardin
peut-être vous même non seulement on
sera plus adapté à vos besoins vos
contraintes mais en plus vous aurez
appris à programmer une carte arduino
ans et s'il vaut mieux si roux quatre
pattes ou encore des chenilles pour
déplacer un panier de linge ou encore
comment fonctionne un réducteur
c'est calme citons également le
mouvement des meilleurs ces personnes
qui fabriquent des choses principalement
des objets 107 fabricants et sans avoir
de savoir faire particulier dans le
domaine
le principe est d'apprendre des autres
via internet ou lors de rassemblements
ce sont des testeurs fou ensemble en
moins einstein cas gaston lagaffe les
rassemblements leur permettent
d'échanger et de se rencontrer
le partage est au centre du mouvement
que ce soit des fichiers 3d ou encore
des lignes de code est toujours un
américain un chinois ou encore un russe
qui a déjà réalisé quelque chose qui
ressemble à ceux dont on a besoin
j'ai eu la chance de participer cette
année au meilleur faire 2016
je suis allé avec botte de carottes et
tous mes amis mes coeur puis à l'uqam
très dense et j'ai pu rencontrer plein
de gens curieux et de gens passionnés et
désirant partager justement leurs
patients tout un chacun peut ainsi se
lancer dans des projets complexes sans
prérequis ou presque c'est une belle
époque pour les petits roboticiens comme
moi ont également que la robotique
domestique est en pleine expansion
si au xxème siècle l'émergence des
robots pourrait faire craindre
l'insurrection
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas avoir
un robot à la maison ne fait plus peur
et robots aspirateurs se promène dans
nos salons le robot de cuisine est
intelligent et la tondeuse pour
l'initiative de démarrer tout cela est
quand même des lames tranchantes vous
êtes reconnu e autonome
qui vient près de vous quand vous faites
assez sur le gazon et ça ne choque
personne
une belle époque de plus si ces robots
nous remplace dans certaines tâches
fastidieuses de notre quotidien ils ne
remettent pas en cause notre savoir
faire et ne remettent pas en cause non
plus notre capacité à nous occuper de
901 quotidien prenons par exemple un
exemple de votre robot de cuisine
il contient sur une carte sd des
dizaines de recettes il pèse des
ingrédients calcule le temps de lever ou
encore le temps de cuisson et il le mix
et mélange mais pourtant ne remet pas en
cause vos qualités de cuisinier la
robotique domestique est un sujet
d'avenir c'est sûr d'abord parce que
c'est un trépas de chômage personne
n'embauche quelqu'un pour arroser ses
quatre malheureux peau de fleurs mais un
robot pourra le faire et en plus en
profitera pour se réveiller
l'appartement en en vacances en somme
c'est le tracteur agricole qui crée du
chômage pas part au vote
de plus tout reste à faire c'est l'heure
des pionniers si les technologies
nécessaires existait déjà il ya qu'avant
c'est maintenant que la révolution arabe
pour conclure si les drones militaires
font la guerre
les robots industriels remplacer
ouvriers les robots domestiques e
n'offriront que plus de temps pour nous
occuper des choses qui ont vraiment de
l'importance
merci
[Applaudissements]